it's time everybody Merry Christmas it's
time for me to play your levels Super
Mario Bros world 1:1 someone remade
Super Mario an ass legend how do I even
can I even do that god damn it
whoa maybe I need a car let's do the
helicopter
the butt propeller of course oh my god
good vehicle come on can you be a little
more [ __ ] there we go but propeller yes
oh god okay oh God go up go up go up
this is how Super Mario was intended we
finally realized how to play it properly
you are welcome why bye Super Mario when
you can buy ants and get soup the better
version for free everybody air begun
yeah just like Shigeru Miyamoto intended
just like you want that's a love God
show me Super Mario
I meant the real Super Mario oh god no
what Oh secret secret oh oh I went down
the pipe haha oh my god I'm so bad at
this oh are you kidding me alright eject
they're weak and I'm back everybody
is there gonna be other is a flank hey
hey that's so creative well done the
Godfather that's awesome you guys are so
talented I am so proud what is this the
deep mines okay
these levels with no vehicles seem very
popular you can't enter the mines yet
you forgot your pickaxe what is this
minecraft what the hell that doesn't
even look like a pickaxe okay fine fine
I'm grabbing the pickaxe you collected
the pickaxe incredible I totally have
the pickaxe right now you may now enter
the cave thank you game Oh No okay all
right be careful you can't
Hey look at that checkpoint everybody
I'm in the cave playing Minecraft this
is great so cute kawaii destiny really
into this techno music it's really good
I did it with my pickaxe everybody gets
to get a like I don't spit [ __ ] but you
know unfair level sure buddy hey it's
another one with the vehicle why did we
even add vehicles in the game what the
hell I gotta go back here oh my god okay
what else you got oh oh no damn it come
on there you go sucking ass thank you
unfair level more like annoying level
okay alright what kill me last time oh
my god well [ __ ] this level okay I
challenge you version eight no problem
look at that easy
look at that no no go back yeah physics
really makes sense in this game don't
worry about it this is just how Isaac
Newton wanted it damn it this is too
tiny bit old to get in come on dude [ __ ]
that this is too hard I can't I can't
Harry Potter chicken parkour 100% legit
Wow that sounds fantastic
oh look it's Harry Potter everybody just
as I remember now you can jump in midair
oh yeah
someone modded I don't know how you did
this that's pretty cool too bad I still
can't get up thing come on come on Harry
Potter there we go Jesus okay well this
is totally not possible yeah no problem
Oh jump oh wow
why do I suck at jumping so much there
it is there it is I'm so good at games
how okay I can't beat it but it was
really cool that you did that
Angry Birds great they're all levels
without the cards oh wait I get the car
okay
now never mind jump to shoot whoa what
oh my god
target one banana oh that is so creative
that is so cool
target two blue crystal okay whoa
I don't think I did it how am I supposed
to hit that great I am so impressed
that's so creative oh there it is yes
perfect
hey wait what target for shoot yourself
to the goal okay okay here I go
okay here we go
ah dared Oh wham and virus well done
that's so cool
as amazing don't mind the curse
okay I won't cuz clearly no one wants
them
oh my job okay I won't mind the cards
don't
oh my god nice shoes don't explode a
she-goat cars please stop stop it
thank you virus at it again you [ __ ]
weirdo
what is this swim fast I'll have you
know I'm an excellent swimmer okay you
know what right the beach I don't need
the car anywhere there we go so excited
oh I got the car again great what it
what is happening
I don't oh but we're in a kook we're in
minecraft again everybody don't worry
about it no no I'm fine
okay we're swimming right we're swimming
okay I did it
okay why do I have to swim fast again
okay there we go
uh-oh all right I'll go this way
oh my god go go go go go go twenty foot
better pie go swim goddamn it you're so
slow dude that [ __ ] just
chilling there oh I'm fine I'm fine
everybody I'm fine in fact I'm doing
excellent thank you for asking how great
are you kidding me there it is there it
is look at the speedboat
look at the galaxy
oh I get it yeah yeah
so go that stain Wow what is happening
now where I go back no no oh I just have
to keep going I just don't know where I
am no don't go back don't go back never
look back on your mistakes and oh god
not again
it's gonna come again no I did it oh wow
I'm free I'm safe Willy oh oh wow so far
so good oh my god go faster
no no no no no no no I don't need this
in my life thank you very much
PewDiePie test number one how old is
PewDiePie
yes oh let's see here oh look at that
I'm 28 by the way not 27 and two old
foot all you think you're smarter than
me okay alright I'm seven sure I'm seven
haha what the hell was the right answer
then wow what a great quiz oh my god it
was a trick question
I fell for my own quest look it's 20
none of these are oh my god incredible
with what words did plead my first video
start what the [ __ ] is that
yeah oh my god I think what the f is
that correct
who is Peter Pan's wife say Yuri Yuri or
not Sookie easy
Yuri best girl oh oh it glitched out
like that's oh of course it's Monica yes
only Monica oh that's awesome
oh no oh oh I made an oopsie oh the game
is breaking it's just Monica hey hey
Monica hey day Monica
hey Monica Hey so fun st guard well done
amazing job to all the people making
levels I'm so proud of it it's so fun
obviously I'm so proud of everyone
making the game as well double moose
check out the game support it I would
really appreciate it and hopefully we
can release very soon on all consoles
thank you very much for watching this
video keep on making levels and as
always squad Fame am